after days of gunfire anti-government
protesters cheer at the site of what is
left of the presidential motorcade
burkina faso special forces turned their
weapons against the president's security
detail several people were wounded
[Music]
what's going on here right now nothing's
going well we expected a lot from
president rock and he's only
disappointed people more with new
appointments always with the new
government but he was the real problem
for the president's party this was an
attempted assassination on a
democratically elected leader hawkman
survived but his time in office was up
a band of soldiers calling themselves
the patriotic movement for safeguarding
and restoration led by this man
lieutenant colonel volori damibe
appeared on state television saying they
had ousted cabaret the government and
suspended the constitution
they forced the defense the movement
which brings together all the components
of the defence and security forces has
thus decided to put an end to the power
of mr cabaret on the 24th of january
2022 a decision taken with the sole aim
of enabling our country to get back on
track and to gather all its forces in
order to fight for its territorial
integrity its recovery and its
sovereignty
faced growing discontent in his
inability to deal with the rising
attacks of armed groups linked to
al-qaeda and isil millions have been
displaced and thousands killed
it appeared to be a mutiny on sunday
with soldiers asking for more means to
deal with the ongoing threats escalated
into a military takeover on monday
with special forces taking over both the
national tv station and the presidential
palace earlier in a tweet president
rockman cabaret asked soldiers to lay
down their arms in the interest of the
nation calling for dialogue
the west african body ecowas called on
the soldiers to return to their barracks
while the eu urged the immediate release
of the president the u.n expressed
condemnation a third coup in west africa
i will say that ecowas the regional
organization has been extremely
responsive uh and and and strong in and
unified in their responses to
uh these coups
after mali
now burkina faso soldiers are yet again
toppling an unpopular but democratically
elected president in the name of the
people promising to restore peace in a
region gripped by violence and
uncertainty nicholas hawk al jazeera